a death game is currently taking place
aboard the black whale 14 princes 14 nbs
far far too many bodyguards and only one
winner hello and welcome to the new old
reveal sourceford well mostly hunter
hunter my name is liam and today i'm
going to tell you everything you need to
know about the succession war this is
part two of a recap series designed to
prep you for the return of the hunt hunt
manga with part one having already
covered everything we know about the
dark continent as well as why we're
trying to get there and in this part
we're going to explore one very very big
problem with this mission as well as why
we may never actually reach the
continent because unbeknownst to the v5
or the hunter association this voyage
has become a battleground for an
entirely separate issue known as the
succession war this is a contest held by
the kakin royalty who were the primary
benefactors of the dark continent
journey and the entire royal family are
housed at the very top of the black
whale in tier one which is a maximum
security space completely off limits to
the rest of the vessel one for obvious
security reasons and two so that nobody
interrupts this very meticulously
planned war the succession war also
known as the succession contest is
actually an ancient ritual instituted by
the very first king of the karkin empire
this was done because in the ancient
days the empire was very weak and
constantly at threat of being engulfed
by neighbouring nations so our first
king guy had to come up with some sort
of method to ensure the safety and
prosperity of kakin and the solution he
found was to conjure an object known as
the cedar confirming that the first king
was an end user and an incredibly
powerful one at that because this object
is easily one of the most overpowered
uses of conjuration that we have ever
encountered in the series which i find
fascinating because it's very unlikely
that the first king was a trained nerd
user the study of nen is actually a
fairly recent development in the grand
scheme of history so this object was
developed out of raw desire to see kakin
thrive and that kind of raw desire is
generally what spawns some of the most
terrifying abilities and this is no
exception the ceo itself is a parasitic
type nine ability which means it
requires the interaction of others to
activate and in this case what seems to
happen is that in exchange for a drop of
blood the seed iron or more accurately
this like funky conjured fairy of the
urn then bestows an egg onto the person
who provides that blood and that egg
will shortly thereafter hatch into a
fully fledged nen beast at the
commencement of the war in the series
these nen beasts have been designated as
guardian spirit beasts but you know the
term is essentially interchangeable now
barring the absurd abilities of dark
continent creatures the cedar is one of
the single most powerful abilities we've
seen and it's because it has the
potential to give birth to an infinite
number of new nan abilities and in the
case of this most recent succession war
it has created 14 guardian spirit beasts
each with their own unique set of powers
but like all things nen great power can
only come at great cost and you can't
just conjure 14 immensely powerful nen
beasts out of absolutely nowhere so
there's an incredibly layered and
complex system of vowels and
restrictions in place to make it
possible many of which we don't know yet
however what we do know is firstly you
must be a prince of the kharkian empire
a blood descendant of whoever the
current king happens to be secondly
these beasts are sustained by the aura
of their hosts basically meaning that
their life force is derived from the
life force of an accompanying prince and
thirdly they can only be summoned under
the conditions of the succession war
which states that only one prince and
one beast will survive the ritual so
this war is designed to determine and
cultivate the strongest possible leader
and ability to continue growing the
khakian empire growing it through a bit
of the old kill murder for example
though king nasa be won the previous war
and he got to keep his beast which is
this very grotesque collection of like
female sex organs and fun fact here
maybe these beasts take the shape of the
desires of their hosts so you can really
see where king nasib's priorities lie
the beasts themselves also have a set of
sub rules though firstly being that they
are invisible to all participants of the
war including the owners of the beasts
themselves however they can be seen by
other general nen users secondly the
guardian spirit beasts cannot fight and
kill one another and thirdly the
guardian spirit beast cannot kill the
host of another beast so not being able
to kill your opponents with your primary
weapon or in fact for that matter not
even being able to see your primary
weapon that'll that sounds pretty
counterproductive for a death game and
the reason for that is because this
contest is designed to be a silent war
which reflects the policies of the
kakian empire forbidding any prince from
murdering another prince even during the
succession war so the goal is to use
these beasts as well as any other
resources to quietly assassinate the
other princes without implicating
yourself oh and i think it's also
important to note that all of the
princes must participate whether they
like it or not most of them do like it
though they like it a lot and we'll
start off with the first prince benjamin
and second prince camilla and also just
a note before my comment section gets
flooded with this within the kakin
empire prince is a gender-neutral term
so everyone is called a prince the
reason why i've paired these two
together however is because these
princes have the distinct advantage of
being trained in end users prior to the
contest benjamin in particular even has
his own private army full of nen users
which well that seems a bit unfair but
hey i guess that's the benefit of being
popped out first and it gets a bit more
wild than that because benjamin's
personal non-ability is called benjamin
baton and it allows him to inherit the
non-abilities of his soldiers once they
die potentially limited by the amount of
fingers that can hold these funky star
things but either way it turns him into
a sort of budget crawler camilla's
personal ability is startlingly relevant
to this whole situation because it's
called cat's name and it makes camilla
nigh on unkillable because if someone
successfully murders camilla it triggers
a counteractive ability spawning this
delightful kitty cat that then sucks the
life force out of the murderer and uses
it to revive camilla from death so one
cannot kill her via conventional means
which is problematic because the goal of
the other 13 princes is to kill that one
as well as 12 more that's not it though
because they are of course both graced
with a guardian spirit beast camillus
has been identified as a basic
manipulator able to take control of
people once certain conditions are met
whilst benjamin's beast is a complete
mystery but it certainly doesn't look
like something i want to experience our
next contestant is third prince zhang
lei who is a very patient and diplomatic
persona he is nowhere near as
bloodthirsty as many of his siblings
seem to be and generally prefers to find
a pacifist solution to any problem now
with that said he also will not hesitate
to brutally murder people so we can't
give him too much credit his guardian
spirit beast is one of the more obscure
of the contest taking on the form of a
dhamma chakra a symbol of the buddhist
religion representing buddhist teachings
and a sense of universal moral order and
with that in mind its ability is to
produce small coins it was speculated by
one of zanglai's bodyguards that these
coins can be used in exchange for
benefits from the nin beast however
zengley himself holds a completely
different theory speculating that these
coins are supposed to be given out to
the people of kakim bestowing the empire
with a power that would consolidate his
rule and potentially make him the
greatest king in all of the history
which is great if he actually becomes
king but it's problematic because that
means that his guardian spirit beast is
less than useful during the actual war
itself which is actually perfectly
representative of the third prince
because he prefers not to act violently
so his nan beast will accommodate this
by not having any combative powers
whatsoever next up though is certainly
our most sickening contestant fourth
prince nick and he is evil in every
traditional sense of the word saradnik
is a twisted art enthusiast whose body
of work consists primarily of bodies
specifically the bodies of young women
who seradnic lures into rooms before
brutally murdering them for the sake of
quote-unquote art it's a bit deeper than
that though because one of seradnik's
core character traits is this deep
hatred of women in general particularly
those that he labels as dishonest women
and he tends to view them more as
livestock and his guardian spirit beast
reflects this by taking the form of a
sort of frankensteined animal with the
head of a woman furthermore the beast's
abilities are directly linked to lying
as should someone lie to saradnik three
times the beast will activate and the
person who committed seppai will quote
cease to be human of all of the terrible
princes which is most of them but of all
of the terrible princes radnick is
undoubtedly the worst possible candidate
to win which is very unfortunate because
he also happens to be a natural nen
genius surpassing the talent of even
gone and killer in fact aside from
marowan we have never seen a more
naturally gifted or a wielder having
surpassed his siblings within mere days
of discovering that nen even exists
during this short time he's also
manifested his own completely separate
to the contest and beast as well as
developed a personal hatsu that allows
him to see 10 seconds into the future to
make matters worse he's also a
specialist which means that his
abilities are limited only by his
personal drive and desire moving down
the spawn hierarchy we arrive at fifth
prince to bepper she is dedicated to the
world of science and holds the values of
modesty and humility above all else
which is why she absolutely despises her
older siblings that we just covered
because they are bad bad people and so
it's actually to beppe's plan to kill
the first four princes but to make peace
with her younger siblings which is nice
and noble and all but sadly the vows and
restrictions required to create the
succession war will never allow for that
scenario to occur having said that tibet
has currently formed a temporary
alliance with serenity recognizing that
the first three princes are more of a
threat or so she thinks and as for her
nin beast it's said to be capable of
producing a wide variety of drugs within
its body however it's only able to do so
with a research partner which we don't
exactly know what is yet sex prince
tyson is and i mean this in the nicest
possible way a blatant cult leader who
is completely opposed to violence and
believes that love will change the world
and by the mere age of well however old
she is now it's not clear this age she
has committed her teachings to a sacred
text known as the book of tyson the
guardian spirit beast is directly
connected to this text as well as it
produces a series of smaller nine beasts
known as eyewogs these creepy crawly
things latch onto people and suck their
aura in exchange for providing the
person with happiness but that amount of
happiness provided is in direct
correlation to how well someone has
studied the book of tyson now if that
sounds familiar then 10 points to you
because this is very similar to the dark
continent creature pat who sucks out
life force in exchange for providing
pleasure to the sucky the goal of
tyson's beast is to accumulate an
overwhelming amount of aura and in fact
it was even described by one of the
characters as being like a spirit bomb
from dragon ball z it's a fair bit more
sinister than that though as should
anyone break the teachings of tyson
after being affixed with an eyewog then
they will suffer a severe punishment and
that sounds like a thing it is that we
do not want seventh prince loserus is
for lack of a better term the dumbass of
the family not the sharpest of minds
however to his credit he does seem like
a pretty cool dude interested in helping
people out in particular he's come up
with a plan to rehabilitate drug addicts
using basho's clean leaf so that's nice
that's a nice thing to do but he also
happens to be the main benefactor of one
of the three major mafia families within
the kakin empire so he may not be all
amazingness all the time as demonstrated
by his guardian spirit beast which we
vaguely know is designed to create traps
so there may be something quite dark
lurking beneath all of the stupidity
here 8th prince salazar is a
sex-obsessed glutton with no real
purpose for living other than placing
things inside and excreting things from
his body and i actually think that's a
fairly generous description because he
spends pretty much all of his time in
the series in bed with an army of women
pleasuring him although to his credit he
is an allegedly amazing rapper however
the person who alleges that is salasali
himself so then take that thought you
will his guardian spirit beast doesn't
matter in the scientists because salazar
wasted it and he's dead now murdered
rather easily am i tired by one of
prince benjamin soldiers it's safe to
say that he was definitely the most
pathetic contestant of the war and that
includes the literal baby that cannot
defend itself before examining said baby
we have another fully grown man in ninth
prince hulkenberg and if the succession
war was unrelated to hunter hunter then
hawkenberg would be our series
protagonist he's an empathetic pacifist
who genuinely cares for his family and
subordinates in fact he was tricked into
participating in the war at no stage was
he told that this would be a death game
so in order to stop the war and protect
his siblings hulkenberg was willing to
kill his father however king nasa be his
own guardian spirit beast prevented this
so hawkenberg then tried to kill himself
to win the war but his bullet was
stopped by his own beast in a moment
that can only be described as ripped
straight out of jojo as can a lot of
this arc by the way the guardian spirit
beast take clear inspiration from jojo's
stance hawkenberg's guardian spirit
beast is more of a support creature it
marks those who are genuinely loyal to
the ninth prince and buffs their aura
quantities and not only that but there's
a multiplying effect whenever
hulkenberg's bodyguards gather together
in a group they become so strong that
it's hypothesized that a handful of
hawkenberg's gods could defeat prince
benjamin's entire army hawkenberg is
also one of the rare princes to have
recently developed his own personal
non-ability called possession error an
unblockable attack said to be invincible
in one-on-one combat after being hit
with an arrow the target is injected
with the consciousness of one of
hulkenberg's bodyguards so essentially
it's a one-hit kill and you get to
control the body of the person
afterwards which is good for all of the
you know sneaky espionage stuff
hawkenberg is a genuinely kind-hearted
man however it seems like his arc in
this war is set up to be rather tragic
an examination of what pushes a person
to do increasingly horrific things
double prince action now with the 10th
and 11th princes kacho and fuguetsu who
we are covering together because they
are intrinsically linked these sisters
grew up together and have what i would
describe as i guess a typical family
relationship which is pretty rare for
this video bugetsu's guardian spirit
beast is quite abstract it's a creature
called secret door and its power can
take fugetsu and kacho to any
destination but it can only be opened by
kacho and of course it can only take
them within the bounds of the war
battlegrounds which we did rather
unfortunately discover when kacho and
fugetsu tried to escape the war and
kacho was killed by these like
miscellaneous ghost hands however that
then activated kacho's guardian spirit
beast called without you which only
triggers once either kacho or fugetsu
dies the beast then assumes the form of
the deceased one and stays with the
other to protect them so fugetsu right
now for all intents and purposes has two
nine beasts twelfth prince mamasay is uh
well she also exists she's a character
who i would describe as a bit
personality-less we didn't really get to
know her a whole lot but she seemed
perfectly pleasant and lovely i guess a
guardian spirit beast was a rather
annoying mouse that would repeatedly ask
a target if they were free and once
someone said yes the mousey thing would
take control of them tragically mamazi
was murdered by her own bodyguard named
tufty in order to gain favor with
whoever ultimately became king however
this backfired pretty tremendously as
tough dee was then later killed by hanzo
in exactly the same way he murdered
momozu so a bit of a sad situation there
but mama said was the first prince to
die which directly led us to a rather
important twist mamasa's body was taken
to the prince's burial chamber a room
composed of these 14 coffin-like things
14 being an interesting number because
in theory only 13 princes are meant to
die during this war so exactly whose
body that 14th coffin is designed for is
unknown but this may be a part of a
greater plan from king nasa be making a
grand sacrifice of all of his children
in exchange for utterly insane power
that or the last coffin could be phenopy
himself because once a new king is
selected there is very little need for
the old king to the opposite of old we
now have young 13th prince mariam a
small child who enjoys video games and
has a pet hamster that's all we know
about him i guess it's kind of sad that
he's participating in a death game but
it is what it is his guardian spirit
beast appears to shrink and grow in
correlation with mariam's feelings
specifically it became a lot more
hostile after the death of his sister
momza it's also suspected as the being
responsible for placing a barrier around
mariam's room which transports anyone
who tries to enter it into a completely
different room so mariam is very well
protected right now which is more than
we can say for 14th prince wobile who is
a literal baby almost always being
cradled by her mother queen oito now at
this point wobel's guardian spirit beast
is the only one that still has yet to
show itself however she has something
that is in my opinion far far more
valuable prince wobile currently has
karapika employed as her bodyguard and
he has sworn to protect her at all costs
however those costs are probably going
to be rather severe as karapika despite
not being a kakin prince has quickly
become the central figure of the entire
succession war which we will be
exploring further in part three